Estados Unidos da un paso más en su
proyecto de regreso a la luna la NASA
dio a conocer la unión de un nuevo
contratista privado a su equipo de
trabajo la empresa escogida es propiedad
de uno de los hombres más ricos del
planeta Jeff
bezosa nosotros la Nasa anunciamos que
Blue origin y sus socios de log Martin
draper boing Astro botic y Johnny borics
construirán un sistema de aterrizaje
humano para llevar a los astronautas de
la NASA a la superficie lunar el
presupuesto asignado al contrato ronda
en los 3.400 millones de dólares el
módulo lunar de Blue origin facilitará
el alunizaje De los astronautas su tarea
consiste en trasladarlos desde una nave
en órbita constante hasta el suelo lunar
y regresarlos al vehículo espacial
queremos establecer la permanencia en la
luna y queremos asegurarnos de tener
acceso constante a la luna con capacidad
para dos personas su diseño ayudará a
permanecer una semana en terreno lunar
se prevé que el módulo se utiliza en la
misión tripulada artemis 5 para 2029
con respecto a las misiones anteriores
el nuevo aparato contará entre otras
novedades con más espacio habitable Blue
origin se suma spacex la compañía de
otro Magnate elon musk esta desarrolla
su sistema starship un nuevo prototipo
de cohete reutilizable con más capacidad
de carga y alcance de lo acostumbrado